[Musique]
au point de départ de cette affaire il y
a une vive émotion nous sommes quelques
jours après l'assassinat de Samuel Paty
le pays est bouleversé par la mort du
professeur de Conflans-Sainte-Honorine
le gouvernement lance plusieurs
chantiers pour répondre à ce drame
terrible Malène Schiappa est alors
ministre délégué à la citoyenneté le 20
avril 2021 elle annonce le lancement du
fond Marianne 2,5 millions d'euros de
subventions pour des associations qui
promettent en ligne le discours
républicain je lance un fond
qui s'applique et qui est un fond qui
vise à financer des personnes et des
associations qui vont porter des
discours pour promouvoir les valeurs de
la République et pour lutter contre les
discours séparatistes
deux ans plus tard deux enquêtes
journalistiques révèlent que deux
associations bénéficiaires du fond
Marianne ont une utilisation douteuse de
leur subventions publiques
face au tollé le Sénat s'empare du sujet
et lance une commission d'enquête
pour faire la lumière sur le fond
Marianne il convoque les principaux
protagonistes de la faire essayer
quelque chose d'extraordinaire avait les
auditions si CAPA une audition ou
n'ayons pas appris un deux trois faits
extrêmement important
le fond Marianne est né d'une vive
émotion en France mais selon les
sénateurs son utilisation a fait l'objet
d'une dérive
aux commandes du Fonds Marianne le CI
PDR il s'agit d'un comité
interministériel dirigé par un préfet
Christian gravelle c'est ce service de
l'administration qui encadrent le fond
Marianne et qui est en lien avec le
cabinet de Marlène Schiappa en audition
il assume en parlant du travail
rigoureux de ses équipes et vante le
bilan du fond Marianne le bilan global
est positif
cela n'a jamais été dit
au final ce soutien financier de l'État
a permis de diffuser auprès de plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'internautes dont
358 000 abonnés plus de 2000
publications en tout genre des postes
d'extraites des tweets des vidéos ou des
podcasts des outils pédagogiques
générant au total plus de 6 millions
d'impressions sur les réseaux sociaux
pour défendre notre modèle républicain
seul regret du préfet les délais de mise
en place du fond Marianne au printemps
2021 l'administration a travaillé dans
la précipitation contre la vie du préfet
Gravel
nous avions proposé un autre calendrier
avec mon équipe nous considérions que
pour effectuer ce travail dans des
conditions optimales
il fallait prévoir un calendrier ces
talents sur trois mois du premier mai à
la fin juillet
le cabinet a demandé à ce que le temps
soit accéléré et qu'on puisse envisager
toute la procédure sur cinq semaines
l'audition est longue et parfois un peu
tendue les sénateurs cherchent à
comprendre comment étaient sélectionnés
les associations et n'obtiennent pas de
réponse à leurs questions je ne sais
toujours pas quelles ont été les
critères qui ont permis d'effectuer la
sélection
et ce qui est aussi important comment
vous avez choisi de d'attribuer des
sommes de plusieurs centaines de
milliers d'euros à certaines
associations et pas d'autres je vais
tâcher d'y répondre monsieur rapporteur
la nature même de cette opération ne
contribue pas à la simplicité sur le
fait de pouvoir envisager une grille
d'analyse commune dès l'instant où il y
a un appel à projet il doit y avoir un
compte rendu de la commission
d'attribution et de sélection et puis il
doit y avoir des éléments tangibles qui
permettent de dire pourquoi telle
association est retenue et pour faire
quoi lorsque l'on voit une procédure
extrêmement opaque au final bien on peut
pas être satisfait par rapport à ce qui
est le principe même d'un appel à projet
une association intrigue
particulièrement la commission d'enquête
lui seppm elle est la principale
association bénéficiaire du fond
Marianne avec
355000 euros cette association est
codirigée par le journaliste et écrivain
Mohammed cifaoui son principal projet
s'appelle hilaïque et le bilan de sa
production interroge avec seulement une
dizaine de courtes vidéos vu quelques
centaines de fois il n'y a pas eu que
comme ça a été dit sous la 3 vidéos avec
15 vues je comprendrais évidemment dans
ces cas-là
le caractère extrêmement problématique
dans ces cas-là de des productions il y
a eu 500 contenus produits par cette
association 3 500 contenus c'est pas
trois vidéos 500 des contenus mais quand
vous nous transmettez le bilan
comment dire à la fois financier morale
un peu de cette association mais on voit
pas 500
contenu il y a eu près de 500 tweets
trade production qui ont été
vous les avez en fait je veux dire parce
que alors on va vous demander aussi si
parce que pour l'instant nous ce qui
nous a été transmis bon c'est
franchement quelques vues enfin c'est
une rare pauvreté je veux dire les
choses faire des tweets d'ailleurs assez
peu vu malgré tout faire des des trades
bon très bien les codes des suites de
tweets bon c'est pas tout à fait ce
qu'on attend quand même avec un montant
de cette nature en face là il y en a
très très peu et puis on a appris de
toute façon y compris de la bouche de
Monsieur Sifa oui que finalement cette
opération c'est à démarrer réellement
en septembre et puis que dès le mois
d'octobre il n'y croit plus et qu'il
considère que le projet est mort voilà
et donc il est tellement mort que
d'ailleurs il ne donne quasiment plus de
signes de vie à son équipe
cette audition ne convainc pas les
sénateurs et quelques jours plus tard un
rapport accablant de l'inspection
générale de l'administration provoque la
démission du préfet Gravel
l'étape suivante pour les sénateurs
recevoir les représentants de l'uspm
Mohamed sefaoui est excusé pour des
raisons médicales c'est Cyril
karunagaran qui représente l'association
devant la commission d'enquête
premier constat cette association ne
semblait pas forcément prête à recevoir
une subvention de 355000 euros on était
cinq à l'association le budget était de
annuel habituel était de 50000 euros
environ
et il est sûr que le fond Marianne est
au-delà du fond Marianne ce projet elle
est modifiée substantiellement notre
budget parce qu'on passait vraiment dans
une
on sait vraiment une nouvelle une
nouvelle activité l'association devait
s'appuyer sur 6 salariés finalement le
projet a été drastiquement revu à la
baisse nous étions 4 donc dont moi-même
monsieur cifaoui et les deux personnes
dont je vous ai parlé la personne qui
était responsable
éditoriale un peu juridique enfin celle
qui était juriste de formation et la
personne pour la production de contenu
vidéo elles ont travaillé effectivement
jusqu'à la jusqu'à la au début 2022
en plein temps au départ il y a une
personne qui est passée en mi-temps
enfin il y a eu quelques ajustements
mais si vous voulez on était grosso modo
sur un sur quatre emplois a priori dans
les salariés on a une personne à
mi-temps toute l'année dans les
documents qu'on a reçu une personne à
plein temps toute l'année une personne a
plein temps pendant 6 mois et une
personne a mi-temps on y vient pendant
six mois et à plein temps pendant deux
mois ce qui revient après
comment dirais-je de deux
équivalent en plein et demi
à temps plein pendant l'année du projet
et non pas 4 par rapport à ce que vous
me disiez donc je veux être sûr que les
éléments
qu'on a reçu analyser correspondent bien
assez de temps plein et demi oui je vous
le enfin je vous le confirme dans la
mesure où j'ai pas fait le calcul
équivalent en plein mais c'était les
quatre personnes effectivement étaient
les personnes qu'on avait embauché
autre information qui interpelle les
sénateurs sur les sommes perçues par
l'uspm 77% sont reversés en salaire
l'essentiel des charges sont devenus des
charges de personnel puisque c'est
pratiquement 80% du budget on avait
l'équipe vraiment minimum qu'on ne
pouvait pas réduire et d'ailleurs je
vous l'ai dit tout à l'heure on a arrêté
les CDD qu'on a gardé on est resté avec
l'équipe moteur on va dire parce que au
bout d'un moment je veux dire si vous
retirez le volant les roues et le moteur
et vous avez plus de voiture enfin de la
même manière
mais par contre vous avez gardé le
carburant puisque les salaires ont été
maintenus à plein pour tout le monde
bien sûr mais tout simplement que si
considère dès le mois d'octobre
c'est-à-dire deux mois après le début de
l'opération quand on n'a pas les moyens
d'agir on doit immédiatement se
rapprocher de l'État pour dire écoutez
on met fin à cette action on ne peut pas
la continuer dans ces conditions et donc
on tire les conclusions et on rembourse
le trop-perçu au lieu de cela et bien
nous avons les des hommes qui ont décidé
de continuer à se rétribuer là-dessus
voilà après c'est pas à moi de dire ce
que cela ce que cela implique c'est le
parti le parquet national financier
éventuellement qui dira ce qu'il a à
dire
l'enquête des sénateurs révèle déjà des
dérives autour du fond Marianne tous les
regards se tournent de plus en plus vers
Marlène Schiappa les sénateurs décident
d'entendre son ancien directeur de
cabinet ils veulent comprendre comment
ont été choisis les associations et au
bout de 2h20 d'audition l'ancien
directeur de cabinet va faire une
révélation
[Musique]
arrêtant comme outil sélection pour l'un
de ces lauréat
une affirmation par la ministre
l'association en question c'est SOS
Racisme une association en conflit
ouvert dans les médias avec Marlène
Schiappa au printemps 2021 cette
déclaration de l'ancien directeur de
cabinet va rebours de ce qu'a dit la
ministre dans les médias depuis
plusieurs semaines où elle assure ne pas
avoir choisi les associations
bénéficiaires du Fonds mariage
aussi quelque chose qui a été dit
notamment par certains responsables et
les filles qui ont dit que j'avais donné
la rue qui avait du copinage ou du
favoritisme je suis amie avec aucun
lauréat du fond Marianne aucun pas un
pas un et mon proche ni personnellement
ni associer ni que sais-je contrairement
à ce que j'ai lu eux-mêmes l'ont démenti
mais après vous voyez à quel point ces
accusations sont difficiles à démentir
prochaine étape désormais recevoir la
principale intéressée ainsi que Mohamed
Sifaoui ils sont tous les deux convoqués
la semaine suivante ce seront les
dernières auditions des sénateurs
en ce qui concerne ma responsabilité je
me défonce pas je me dére pas je suis là
devant vous et j'entends endosser ma
responsabilité toute ma responsabilité
pardon pour la formulation mais aussi
rien que ma responsabilité j'ai toujours
en toute circonstances pris à mes
responsabilités j'ai énormément de
défauts mais certainement pas celui de
me dérober se dérober c'est pourtant ce
que va faire Marlène Schiappa à
plusieurs reprises elle assure ne pas se
souvenir de ce qui s'est joué en 2021 et
renvoie vers ses équipes du ministère de
l'intérieur ou dit ne passer d'avoir
donné de consigne notamment avec la
subvention de SOS Racisme j'en ai pas
souvenir mais manifestement j'aimais un
avis défavorable en disant que pour
à retenir mon ancien directeur de
cabinet fait état de relations
personnelles de désaccord personnel que
j'aurais avec monsieur le Président des
SOS Racisme je n'ai pas là non plus on
me prête beaucoup de relations
personnelles mais je n'ai pas de
relation personnelle ni de désaccord
personnel anciens ou récent avec
monsieur le Président de SOS racistes
nous avons des désaccords sur des points
madame la ministre je vous arrête parce
que le temps court et qu'il faut avancer
mais reconnaissez que il y a quelque
chose qui va pas vous nous racontez
votre vision des choses
on vous entend
très bien mais nous celle que l'on a
n'est pas la même donc quand vous dites
d'abord comme vous dites
le préfet j'allais etc j'ai parfaitement
confiance à lui mais il a dit des choses
qui sont fausses globalement c'est ce
que vous dites je ne dis pas que ce sont
des choses fausses mais c'est de
l'interprétation bah non c'est pas une
interprétation elle a beaucoup
contourner les questions je pense
qu'elle était dans une vision qui était
d'en dire le moins possible la
commission d'enquête tout simplement
peut-être parce que elle avait été
briefée sur le sujet pour des raisons
liées à la présence du parquet national
financier que peut-être la considérer
que et il fallait pas trop en dire à la
commission qui est on l'a regretté
évidemment
lors de cette audition Marlène Schiappa
évoquait le même un email seul trace
qu'elle dit à avoir de son engagement
dans l'affaire j'ai des membres de mon
cabinet qui reçoivent monsieur cifaoui à
une reprise lorsqu'il présente un projet
il dit qu'il a un projet de contredours
sur le cyber islamisme et c'est à cette
occasion que mon cabinet m'adresse un
mail c'est le seul trace écrite que j'ai
relative un rendez-vous entre des
membres de mon cabinet et Monsieur
Sifaoui et dans ce mail il m'explique ce
projet c'est à ce mail d'ailleurs que je
réponds puisqu'il me détaille les
montants du projet et je réponds pardon
pour la familiarité mais c'est un
échange qui a évocation à ce moment-là
être personnel je réponds ceci 300ke
d'argent de l'État pour ce projet ça me
paraît énormeissime le côté compliqué de
se mêle en fait elle répond à ce mail
avant même qu'un dossier soit déposé par
l'uspm autrement dit la question de
savoir ce qu'on allait donner à l'USPPM
était tranchée avant même qu'un dossier
arrive dans les mains du secrétaire
général madame la mini je vais rester
sur la chronologie des faits parce que
j'ai toujours à ce stade quelques
difficultés à m'y retrouver est-ce que
c'était finalement une subvention
fléchée avant même
le fond Marianne je ne peux pas vous
dire Monsieur le Rapporteur ce qui a
procédé au changement de montant dans la
demande
je vais revenir
c'est une question importante ce qui ne
va pas et finalement ce qui fait dire à
l'IGA c'est très important que c'est des
ni transparents ni équitables c'est que
des associations ont finalement fait
l'objet d'arbitrage par votre cabinet
préalablement à toute demande et à tout
dépôt de dossier et ça c'est excusez-moi
de vous le dire c'est votre mail même
que vous nous avez transmis pour comment
dire exprimer votre position sur les 300
000 qui dit ça je me suis à ce dont je
dispose ce dont je dispose c'est
qu'effectivement manifestement les
membres de mon cabinet tout comme le
cipdr était en soutien de l'initiative
portée par Monsieur cifaoui leur mail
démontre qu'ils ont un enthousiasme
vis-à-vis du projet de Monsieur Sifaoui
ça ne moi je n'ai pas d'éléments qui
vise à dire que le cabinet aurait à ce
moment-là arbitrer ou décider quelque
chose avant le comité de sélection
que le choix de l'ufpm et quand je dis
de l'USPPM on comprend bien qu'il s'agit
de Monsieur Sifaoui la décision est
prise hors de tout débat et de toute
comment dire de toute vérification de la
qualité du dossier voilà et donc c'est
contraire si je puis dire à ce qu'a pu
dire dans les médias notamment la
ministre précédemment pour expliquer que
c'était pas du tout mêlée de ces sujets
bien sûr que si
en amont et puis on l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure en aval pour également retirer à
tel ou telle association une subvention
sur des critères qui sont encore obscurs
on va dire au cours de cette audition
les sénateurs en profitent pour dénoncer
le faible suivi par la ministre du fond
Marianne
il y a eu une forte annonce puissante
communication et après plus rien oui je
voulais répondre bien sûr merci monsieur
le rapporteur
je vais répondre très très vite comme
une question au gouvernement simplement
vous dire que il n'y avait pas plus rien
et il y a matérialité dans les échanges
de mails entre mon cabinet et moi-même
et des notes dans lesquelles nous
voulons relancer le fond mariage il y a
une note de projet suite à la demande de
ma part et à échange et suite justement
à discussion avec le cabinet
l'administration sur ce sujet l'un de
mes conseillers prépare un futur appel à
projet pour l'année qui suit sur le fond
Marianne nous voulons nous entendons
poursuivre cette politique publique
d'accord mais donc vous conviendrez et
vous ne m'avez pas démenti qu'il n'y a
pas de communication particulière
après le lancement il y a l'annonce du
fond Marianne il y a la sélection le
projet
vit sa vie
il y a plus de communication voilà il
n'a plus une bénéficie plus du même
portage et surtout du même éco
médiatique la responsabilité d'un
ministre ne s'arrête pas au lancement
d'une opération la responsabilité du
ministre s'arrête aux résultats et
lorsqu'on a effectivement obtenu des
résultats on peut d'ailleurs revenir
devant les Français et devant la presse
pour faire état de résultats c'est très
important c'est ça la responsabilité
ministérielle et d'une certaine façon
elle déni un peu cette responsabilité
reste un protagoniste Mohamed Sifaoui ce
journaliste spécialiste des réseaux
islamistes est au cœur de l'affaire et
devant les sénateurs il dit jouer son
honneur il revient sur sa relation avec
Marlène Schiappa elle n'est pas mon ami
elle a pas été elle est pas aujourd'hui
elle sera encore moins demain vous savez
pourquoi je dis ça je devais pas le dire
dis ça parce que je n'aime pas les gens
qui n'ont pas de courage
je ne respecte pas les gens qui n'ont
pas de courage je vous l'ai dit Madame
Schiappa est innocente mais je l'ai dit
deux dès le départ son attitude est
curieuse elle a une attitude de
quelqu'un qui est coupable mais elle est
coupable de rien et je le redis devant
vous et je lui je lui redis
nous ne parlons pas de culpabilité donc
elle a une attitude de coupable c'est
moi qui le dis elle a son attitude si
j'étais un observateur extérieur de
cette affaire je dis tiens madame
Schiappa quelque chose à se reprocher et
c'est bizarre n'a rien à se reprocher
plus tard dans son propos le polémiste
accusera certains politiques de
l'acheter une audition marquée par un
niveau de tension encore jamais atteint
au Sénat
vous êtes parfaitement je dirais sur la
même
posture ou explication que la ministre
c'est-à-dire que vous êtes
concerné par le projet mais vous
finalement vous tenez à distance pour
qu'il n'y ait je dirais pas de souci
je ne vous permettra
je ne précise rien du tout vous allez
retirer tout de suite ce que vous voulez
dire aucune posture chez moi vous
entendez il y a aucune posture je ne
suis pas un homme politique déclaration
vous retirez tout de suite je n'ai rien
de comparable avec Madame c'est clair
celui qui persévère est toujours en
difficulté au final bon et peut-être y
a-t-il là une façon de vouloir
se sortir de questions qu'il embarrasse
tout simplement voilà ça en dit long
aussi quand même sur la qualité du
partenaire pour l'État
et je pense que
malheureusement pour lui monsieur
Sifaoui n'a pas donné une bonne image
lors de cette audition je vous le dis
vous faites un raccourci malheureux vous
ne comparez à Madame Schiappa je n'ai
absolument rien absolument pas ce que
j'ai mis sur le fond sur la force c'est
clair c'est mais alors d'abord vous
n'avez pas de ni d'ordre ni je vous
demande d'aller
excusez-moi je pense que vous devez
garder et vos nerfs et votre maîtrise
nous essayons de le faire et poursuivons
et je vous le dis je suis quelqu'un vous
savez je suis quelqu'un d'assez entier
je respecte les institutions et je
respecte les gens qui me respectent mais
j'ai le moment où on me respecte plus je
vais aller sur un autre temps je vous le
dis tout de suite je pense qu'il
cherchait un peu l'incident pour tout
dire bon ça se fait sur cette phrase du
rapporteur ça aurait pu être sur une
autre c'est même peut-être interrogé
pour savoir si à un moment donné il
voulait pas quitter là la séance vous
voyez je pense que à la fois moi-même et
le rapporteur nous avons gardé notre
calme
pour pouvoir poursuivre parce qu'il
était important d'aller jusqu'au bout de
cette audition au cours de cette
audition Mohamed Sifaoui va faire une
révélation au sénateur dès l'automne
2020 il était présent quasi
quotidiennement dit-il auprès des
équipes du ministère de l'intérieur vers
la mi-novembre Christian gravelle m'a
fait savoir qu'il était gêné par le fait
de me solliciter au quotidien et qui
comptait sur mon application et que je
serai de toute façon rémunéré et qu'il a
eu l'accord de la ministre d'accord et
ça donc cela a fait l'objet d'un devis
et d'une facture en bonne et due forme
qui qui était me semble-t-il lorsque je
sache maintenant après il faut voir
comment fonctionne cette administration
et comment fonctionne ce gouvernement on
n'a pas fait ça je vous le rassure au
sous-sol d'un café dans le 20e
arrondissement on a fait ça dans des
ministères en bonne forme avec des
sociétés qui existent des factures on a
plein de temps d'un côté
et d'un autre côté nous avons des
actions supplémentaires donc de
consultants qui sont mises en place par
le cpdr et dont on n'avait pas
connaissance jusque là donc voilà c'est
double financement si je puis dire d'un
même organisme public pour des actions
qui a priori ne pourraient pas se faire
en même temps puisqu'il y a déjà un
emploi à plein temps et puis il y a
également un montant qui est finalement
fixé une fois pour toute pour des
actions à venir et non pas sur service
fait là aussi c'est très rare de la part
de l'état de payer des prestations qui
ne sont pas faites
le 6 juillet la commission d'enquête
rend ses conclusion les sénateurs ont
intitulé leur rapport font Marianne la
dérive d'un coup politique
en lisant le rapport vous constaterez
qu'à toutes les étapes de ce projet le
manque de rigueur
l'opacité et je le dis la désinvolture
on conduit au fiasco
dans leur travail les sénateurs sont
très sévères sur la gestion politique du
dossier par Marlène Schiappa et ses
collaborateurs le cabinet de la ministre
et la ministre délégué en outrepassé
leur rôle en appuyant d'abord la
candidature de l'USSE ppm en amont du
comité de sélection en revenant sur
l'octroi d'une subvention de 100000
euros à l'association SOS Racisme alors
même qu'une décision favorable du comité
de sélection a été intervenu
lors de cette conférence de presse les
deux sénateurs annoncent avoir relevé de
nouvelles informations qui pourraient
intéresser la justice le président rénal
a saisi le parquet national financier
d'un complément d'information en
application de l'article 40 du code de
procédure pénale en lui transmettant un
certain nombre de documents obtenus dans
le cadre de notre mission
fiasco gâchis les sénateurs disent
dresser un constat sans appel dans un
combat pourtant essentiel et légitime la
lutte contre la radicalisation
nous avons le sentiment que le fond
Marianne a été conçu comme une grande
opération de communication par la
ministre
alors que la discrétion et l'efficacité
aurait certainement dû constituer les
lignes directrices majeures le label du
fond Marianne devient un véritable
fardeau
je dirais même un boulet attaché à
l'élégorie de la République
[Musique]
le plus grave dans l'affaire selon les
sénateurs c'est la promesse rompue
formuler après la mort de Samuel Paty
par son manque d'éthique et de
transparence le gouvernement a entaché
la mémoire du professeur d'histoire-géo
l'attention aurait dû être maximale sur
ce dossier elle est maximale parce que
c'est sur la base
d'un assassinat horrible que c'est dans
la mémoire de beaucoup de Français et
que donc par rapport à cela on a une
exigence de faire au mieux bien sûr le
fond Marianne n'aurait pas tout résolu
bien entendu mais au moins le mener dans
la continuité moi je comprends
parfaitement que la famille du
professeur que vous avez cité ne
souhaite plus que ce nom soit associé à
cette affaire du fond Marianne
[Musique]